yeah welcome to this video playing FM
Alec 805 come on let's go to main line
or the Queen's onion hmm alright yeah I
tried this pawn sacrifice just a couple
of games ago but it hey I I really don't
know is there anything about that and I
quickly got a really bad position this
is the the traditional way to play that
and ya thang t 555 ok but I don't have
so much experience with the Queen's
Indian anyway I am I always played
Knight c3 in my own games going going
for the NIMS la3 be formed the saw this
right I don't know yeah something like
this is probably right ok ok 95 from gap
I thought before or is it is my center
too shaky and I can take everything off
nights not to e4 then a five maybe maybe
I just said is a bit shaky ok but I
don't see how to how to play Oh
interesting
and I didn't didn't expect that more
okay
where does he go now with this night and
this good enough for four white island I
don't I don't get it ready night a six
look so when I know it looks very
vulnerable and it's off side of course
sorry off side piece okay taking take e6
or queen a form a BM Queen a form and
the Rope do you want something like this
this maybe is right I take is six
minutes to go fishing g2 anyway first 24
I like this Queenie fumbles maybe
playing rock do you one next of course
I'm not I don't think I'm threatening
much with d6s d 2 nite is hanging so de
takes on g2 King takes takes only six
this may be playable for him because the
night is hanging but I have then rock t
1 so maybe it is threatening after all
okay should I take it if i take it takes
takes rocky one the light squares are
weak is got weak light squares I'm
spending too much time here again
yeah the lights qui assets wait I can
take a night beehive writers this looks
looks quite good how does he protect
this night a six I have fast c5 all this
work the aid I cannot call 97 so we're
be three RF three let's go here with
this idea of pushing c5 I have roped the
aids in this this position this rook
only seven is blocking
you
intending to take on V 6 a-6 I take
an a6 that can even take c7 rook c7c be
60 this is nice a 697 okay a successor
is bad anyway but i'm not sure what here
what is playing now okay
f1 i gom takes takes 97 is not so great
I like the idea of playing c6 and rock
t7 something like this it's not not so
much we ever manage this okay just
preparing it for to get the night here
on c6 would be a very nice post
should be two wheels is one thing that I
need to take care just take it on now
I'd like to play be five but he's got I
got this poppy tools okay take it no
just a four am pinning down this
weakness on 85 I can take take it at
home work
check-check
now it's a bit tricky with the time
position s it's just just winning for
white but need to be don't don't have
much time of course time warning
I've okay i just i just spent too much
time in the middle of this it's just bad
play now it's it's not even winning for
black i mean i just i get the pawns aah
chak chak course new draw otherwise he'd
never win a game gotta make sure that
you win at least once in a while on time
yeah why oh yeah it's probably even work
I don't know if it's better for white I
cannot lose ever yeah i just i just
spent far too much time looking at this
nice position it sometimes happens I
mean this is very nicely dominating
black the knight on c6 and I just take a
five and it's it's just it's just
nothing good black and do here yes what
what's the computer plus 3 or 2.6 yeah
okay it's an i just spent too much time
and didn't speed up enough enough to do
together to get this to draw but yeah so
he never he never accepted of course
alright thanks